thank you all again for coming to the
Wolfram technology conference it is my
pleasure to introduce the main event for
this evening our founder and CEO Stephen
Wolfram all right we'll hello everyone
so here we are again so next I think I
think this is the 29th technology
conference that we've had if you count
back to the the very first pre
technology conferences and and next year
June 23rd it will be 30 years since the
release of Mathematica version 1.0 which
means it's also 30 years since what we
now call Wharton language was launched
and it's gone kind of from the it's gone
from something from that to whoops we
are on the wrong thing there we go okay
it's gone from that to to this over the
past 30 years and it's some it's
interesting to realize that actually 30
years is about half the time since the
very first computer languages were were
invented and I think it's it's been a
long process for us over these 30 years
but gradually we've built something
that's both incredibly unique and I
think also incredibly important the
challenge now is to get it used in the
world in the way that it should be but
and that that all starts with people
here many of you have been working with
walking language for a very long time
understand it very deeply now we kind of
need to get it deployed better in the
world and I think sometimes when we're
when we're in the middle of what we're
doing we kind of lose sight of how kind
of historic and intellectual achievement
we're dealing with I mean I I see the if
you look at kind of the arc of
computation kind of begins with people
programming machines and machine code
and then about 60 years ago the first
computer languages
to arrive and then sort of the next
layer of computation was operating
systems and then user interfaces then
maybe they're things like mobile and the
web that come in there and then what we
have now is kind of a new layer of
computation the kind of knowledge-based
computation layer and that's what we've
built with Wolfram language over the
over these last thirty years now the
challenge is to make that layer
ubiquitous to make it like operating
systems and UIs and so on something that
one can expect to take for granted in
all of the computation that people do
and all of the things that people build
with computation so that it's some it's
really it's really something you can
always depend on being there so we've
been building what we call our hyper
architecture to make that possible
something that goes across cloud and
desktop and servers and mobile are
embedded and distributed and so on in
all of those different environments
deploying Wolfram language so that you
can really rely on it being there
whenever you're doing computation in any
form so I'm going to be talking about
lots and lots of things to do with this
hyper architecture here today you can
kind of think of this talk as kind of a
table of contents of much of what we're
doing and what's going to be covered by
other Wolfram speakers at this
conference and I would also say if
there's something you're interested in
and you can't find a talk about it then
please go ask the organizing folk and
they'll probably try and find somebody
who can talk to you about that
particular topic so what I'm gonna do
here is I'm going to talk a little bit
about what's happened with our
technology stack over the past year and
then a bit about what's coming in the
future
so first what has happened well you can
always look see you can look at that's a
good you can look at my Twitter stream
to find out you know always look at my
Twitter stream to find out things that
are happening so to speak and it's some
we've got we've got really a huge
pipeline of R&D which is sort of the
payback from 31 years of systematically
building Wolfram language and building
our company and all our capabilities
we've sort of created this wonderful
machine for doing R&D and and creating
products as I
talk about repeatedly here I think our
challenge is to take what we felt and
really make sure it's used in the world
to its full potential but first of all
let's talk about what we've built so one
thing that's that's happened is that
kind of our rate of doing Rd has
increased and one of the challenges now
is to figure out how to deliver sort of
this increased rate of Rd production we
used to wait kind of several years often
between releases of our product we've
speeded that up greatly so this time
last year we just released version 11.04
from language now between that time and
now we've released eleven point one and
eleven point two and these point one
releases are not small like if you look
at kind of the word cloud for this is
some of that that's new and eleven what
was new and eleven but if you look at
the word cloud for eleven one those are
all new functions in eleven one an 11 to
same kind of story lots of lots of new
functions and that those are sort of
we've kind of inflated the notion of a
point one release now it's something
much bigger you might ask why aren't
these integer releases of our product
I'm kind of the strategy that we're
adopting is that energy releases are
things that release full new stories in
new areas and the the the issue is were
producing so much stuff all the time how
do we deliver that in it on a timely
basis to people so point one releases
kind of have whatever is ready when the
train leaves for that release so to
speak so it might be highlights of a new
area it might be infrastructure that's
building out a new area or it might even
be pretty much the whole new area
because it happened to be ready but
we're not sort of guaranteeing that the
whole new area is ready for each point
one release that's that's really
reserved for integer releases and some
things in point run releases are marked
as experimental even still an entity
releases statistically very few of those
experimental things will change when
they stop being experimental but they
might we're kind of proud of maintaining
compatibility in our system across 30
years and so when the thing stops being
experimental we really think we're
committing to it for the long term so if
you only use what we documented as not
being experiment
then we'll really work hard to maintain
compatibility for that and they have to
be really really good reasons for us to
actually change something there's an
experimental usually there'll be kind of
a design bridge between what we had and
what we want to have okay so let's go
through a little bit about some what's
new now in what's been new in over this
past year inversions 11.1 11.2 we can
start off with the the route guide page
as we call it so we can just go well we
can't go to the one on the web I guess
so this is the the route guide page you
find the same thing in the on the
desktop if you want to and now let's
let's some okay we'll stick here and so
you in the in the kind of the summary of
what's in the language you'll see there
are a couple of new tiles one for
machine learning one for knowledge
representation and a natural language
those represent kind of the the
blossoming of those two areas in our
system that have caused us to kind of
define them as as new sort of top-level
top-level areas in the system so if you
go and look here in in in the product
you're in in the documentation as people
know the you can go from this kind of
route guide page down to to these some
other guide pages which then lead to
individual function pages one of the
things that we've done recently is if
you look at a typical function page now
one of the things you'll see here is
there started to be diagrams in the in
the kind of details section here another
thing that you'll notice is that when
you first open the page one of the
issues has always been there really is
useful stuff in the details if you need
to look at the details but often you'll
just scroll down and start looking at
examples and you don't want to mess
around with the details so we've tried
to design a good kind of information
presentation that lets you get to where
you want to get to
and in order to make kind of an
attractor for people to actually open
the details there's a thumbnail of
what's in the details just to just to
convince you that's going to be good and
interesting stuff there and sometimes so
another thing that you'll find on on
some pages now is the section called
background and context there's kind of
an essay that puts into context the
operation of this particular function
and kind of describes in more discussive
way the what what's going on there
and you'll find a number of these
scattered through documentation
particularly emphasizing things like I
don't know image forests and components
where you might not know what the point
of image forest in components is and so
there's kind of a narrative description
of that by the way don't forget that in
in in documentation there's this very
nice feature that from web documentation
you just click it and it will copy it
and now if you go to here if you go to
to the actual product let's say on the
desktop you can just paste it and you'll
get some you'll get the result I have no
idea what this particular thing is we
can try it run it and see what it does
um I don't seem to take it's got a load
something okay um well well that's
thinking about that we can keep going so
well let's start
boy that was an example I shouldn't have
tried um the what is it doing
my guess image foresting components may
be hard to compute maybe there's a big
complicated image who knows or maybe
nothing is working here I'm not sure
we'll see um okay so so um let me start
off I want to start talking about a lot
of different areas that's really odd um
let me just hmm that's even more out
that it doesn't that is extremely odd
let's try just quitting entirely and see
what happens
I am very suspicious here um
okay let's see I'm just going to try
let's just see what that nothing works
okay
that's a good sign the maybe I can try
running this again maybe it'll work in
an instant should I try that maybe this
is really hard okay
there now something is wrong here
hmm okay well anyway um all right well
let's let's keep going anyway so what I
want to talk about first was machine
learning and we've had we kind of have a
very leading edge set of things and
machine learning we have for for quite a
number of years now one of the things
that's important about machine learning
is deeply integrating it into often
language and we're also kind of
providing another level of functionality
for machine learning itself so let's
start off with a simple example here let
me see if I can let's see if anything
works here I'm I'm a little bit
concerned about what is going on but
let's see um okay so let's just this is
very odd it's very slow okay so what I
just did there was a just a web search
we'll talk a little bit later about
these integrated services that make use
of external API is an often language but
I'm just going to use it for for for for
this purpose here so I can pick up one
of these images and let's say I want to
just saying image identify of that image
so now it might have to might load the
the classifier here and then it will go
ahead and be able to answer the question
of what that bird is it says it's
European Goldfinch word so let's try
this one here let's see so we can we can
go ahead and so this is an example of
something we've had for actually about
two and a half years now our image
identifier has gotten a little bit
better but this is kind of kind of it
what's really interesting about this is
how it's built deeply into the language
that is whatever you're doing in the
middle of some other computation you
could say okay I need to
identify what that images are and the
you can just use this function image
identify and it has lots of options and
different possibilities for it and and
the other thing in terms of building
this image identifier this is very
state-of-the-art maybe the best image
identifier general-purpose image
identifier that exists the the main
thing that is particularly unique about
what we did is we did a good job on the
curation of the images and that's sort
of something that follows our kind of
long history now of doing data curation
now for images as well as for other
kinds of data so but what's really
interesting about this is not just the
the pure image identifier it's the fact
that we can we can use it to we can use
this image identifier we can use what's
inside this image identifier to build a
feature extractor that can work on any
image and that allows us to much more
easily much more automatically set up
more machine learning for images so let
me show you an example of that so let's
go ahead and let's generate let's just
generate a couple of other examples here
let's generate some thumbnails of fish
let's generate some thumbnails of fowl
here and then what we're going to do is
we're going to try and train a
classifier to to recognize fish from
fowl so let's let's generate our
training set here so there's just going
to combine it's going to say the fish of
fish and the foul or fowl and now it's
going to say make a classifier now
what's going to happen here is something
that's that's new in the latest 11.2
you're going to see it very
automatically figuring out how to make
the best possible classifier for fish
versus fowl given the simple data and so
it will make use of the feature
extractors that we'll learnt from our
big image identification system and then
it will figure out the best method to
use to distinguish these things and
you'll kind of see it do its thing I'm
describing because I think it's going to
happen quite quickly but maybe it won't
so right right now it's actually using
the feature extractor to to figure out
okay so that was too fast the if you'd
watch that more carefully you would have
seen it try various different methods to
optimize what kind of classifier it was
going to build well so now if we want
let's pick up some more let's get
20 kind 20 fish instead of 10 fish there
so it's got our pictures here and now we
can take this classifier that was just
built and let's say let's apply that
classifier to all these fish and let's
see what it does and ok they're all
fishy the the but but what's important
there is that this was we only trained
it on a very small number of examples
and the fact that that was possible was
because we were leveraging this whole
feature extraction system that came from
the curation and the building of the
image identifier etc etc etc ok well so
now let's let's go ahead and see what we
can kind of go well actually here let me
just show something here this is this is
kind of showing inside the image
identifier that's showing the actual
neural network that's inside the image
identify when click and drill down and
see all kinds of detail here if we want
to but that that is the image identifier
and if we go ahead and that that's the
original image identifier not the
feature extractor that's the original
image identifier we go ahead and use
this image identifier on some particular
piece of data and we'll find you know
just pick this whole thing up and we can
just apply that to a picture of a fish
and it will probably tell us something
about what it is so that's that's just
showing kind of the insides of what's
happening in this you're on that oh I
see what happened
oops that's not going to work I have to
I'm really abusing the system today no I
did something I did something totally
crazy here oh well um ok all right well
anyway so so let's let's keep going
let's sum this whole idea of using
feature detectors oh come on let's stop
stop stop stop I wonder if I have
disabled somehow by something that I've
done to set up this talk I wonder if I
have disabled the ability to quit
anything I think I have I have a
suspicion that I have remapped some
the the key combination that does that
oh well um okay so let's go back here
and let me let me show you something
else that becomes possible as a result
of as a result of having feature
extractors built in so here's his
Russian alphabet so now what we can do
is we can say make us a feature space
plot treating each of those letters just
rasterizing each letter treating as a
bitmap just make a feature space plot
that shows us kind of where in feature
space each of those letters lies so the
letters that look similar with respect
to the feature extractor that was built
from the 30 million images that were
used to train the image identifier
that's being used to determine what
similarity means in this space and
that's the result that we get well so
let's some let me try showing you what
it looks like if you do a sort of
complete training from scratch of
something like a neuron that so first
thing we have to do is get some training
data so here let's let's read in some
training data this is I'll talk later
about our data repository but this is
just something that appears in the data
repository this is a standard training
set of handwritten digits
now let's sum let's use this as a net
model gives us sort of standard models
we'll talk about that some more later
standard models of neural nets this is a
there's a simple one this is an
uninitialized neuron that so I could
just say so if I just say net initialize
of that
Lynnette thing I will get a network and
I can apply that Network if I want to to
see if I can do this here yeah so I
could apply that network to a zero and
I'll get something totally random
because this neuron that was was
initialized completely random or the
neuron that knows nothing right now but
let's say I want to train the neuron
that using let's say a sample of that
original data so now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to say net train that
network on a random sample of 2,000
entries in that original data so what
you'll see here is the thing will
gradually it's showing the loss the the
rate of errors in the training set it's
showing the loss gradually decreasing
and it'll go he'll keep going down and
gradually I could stop it if I want to
at an intermediate point but it will
gradually produce something that it
thinks is a decent decent network for
for recognizing things and if I take
that network and apply it take that and
apply it to that zero it'll probably
give me zero okay so that's what it
looks like to do neuron that training in
the system it's a very automated thing
at this point so the it's yeah so we can
now look at this this whole structure
here is kind of a symbolic
representation of neuron that's and it's
it's something where we can if we want
to actually maybe I can show you here
let's look in this case we can just look
inside this neuron that what what it is
doing when it I when it identifies the
zero so for example I could say take in
percent seven let's take the first five
levels of the neuron that's let's apply
that to the zero and then we'll see kind
of inside the brain of the neuron that
what it was thinking of okay it's a big
mess we could say for example let's
let's use let's just make images out of
those pieces okay so that's that's kind
of intermediate features intermediate
things that the neural s is identified
and if we wanted to we could say make a
feature space plot of those so that will
give us some sense of what the different
feature is being identified by the
neuron that's at an intermediate stage
they were kind of using machine learning
to analyze what's happening inside a
machine learning system and this is the
kind of thing that that you can expect
to work in with the kind of symbolic
structure that we have in Morphin
language so let's see at the I mean just
to explain something about how this
whole structure works it's at the lowest
level this is using a thing called
airmax net it could be using tensorflow
also it's using kind of a low-level
highly efficient system for putting
neural nets onto hardware and it gets
optimized for all kinds of hardware and
GPUs and so on we make
this big symbolic layer together with
all of the automation that allows you to
to construct neural nets and make them
work to train them all of the pre
trained classifiers all this kind of
thing by the way I might mention that
that out of this whole pipeline you can
generate standalone neural nets that
will run in a max net and so on so one
of the things that's that's great about
this is you can really understand it
makes it a lot easier to understand
machine learning I even put I put a
section in my this is a much expanded
section in the second edition of my
elementary introduction wolfmann
language and I even wrote a blog post
recently called machine learning where
is it come up now where does it go a
little blog post No
why did that not come up they well it's
a very odd um I wrote a blog post here
we go called machine learning for middle
schoolers which was my attempt to
explain how one can understand machine
learning at a pretty elementary level
using the kind of high level constructs
that we have this turns out this blog
post seems to be quite popular among
people although the middle school is -
but um at least I'm defining a standard
there okay well so we can look at if we
wanted to we could look at kind of what
an ab initio neural network looks like
let me go quickly through this on - so
this would be um there we go so this is
this is what a single layer of a neural
network looks like if we take that
single layer and we just it just takes a
vector of two things as input it
produces and that's what it does as its
as it's sort of that's what the the
single layer does we could just plot you
know this layer is just like a function
just takes two parameters as input and
then generates output this is the first
coordinate of the output now if we
wanted to we could say now we could say
let's let's use the slightly more
complicated one let's make this little
network here that's a little stack of
things now we can say oops let's say we
just want to plot that Network as a
function of its two parameters so it's
some
random it's been initialized randomly so
it's making that random crinkly surface
if we do that we can say okay that gives
if we apply that neuron that to that
little vector it'll make that okay let's
try and do something more interesting
let's try and train that network that we
just made that little tiny network there
let's try and train that Network on the
function X Y goes to sine X Y ok so
we'll see it training here seems to have
kind of bottom doubt there and okay we
can we can stop its training now perhaps
and just take the result that we got
from that this thing we're calling T net
and let's try plotting that and see what
it looks like well it's not a totally
terrible approximation to plot of sine X
Y not great I mean let's see what it
actually should look like but that was
that was from a that tiny neural net
with a tiny amount of training there
let's say we let's let's make a slightly
more complicated neuron that let's say
we let's do yeah what I want to do here
we want to more complicated one I don't
think so let's try here we go let's try
this um let's try making that neuron
that's out of a whole sequence of ramps
and linear layers okay so there's a
deeper deeper learning neural nets and
now let's try taking that neuron that
and let's try training that neuron that
will probably take a little bit longer
to train because it's a deeper neuron
that well we see actually the loss is
still going down that's an encouraging
sign and let's keep it going for a
little while longer okay maybe it's
maybe we can stop it now let's stop it
there and let's try it again let's see
what let's see what it looks like when
we try plotting that again and we see
it's a really pretty good approximation
to that original sign X Y so that's kind
of a benicio machine learning being
Illustrated so and what's interesting
about this I mean the this is kind of a
there there are many areas to which this
kind of thing can be applied not just
traditional machine learning machine
vision things like this but also what
will emerge over the next couple of
years probably as numerical analysis
will get revolutionized probably control
theory signal
saying plus putting and in fact we are
putting machine learning like this it's
sort of a a new generation of
interpolation like things and we're
putting this kind of technology into the
core of many algorithms in our in our
system in particular starting with
things like image processing and text
analysis so one of the things that we're
both using this kind of symbolic
structure of Wolfram language to make it
easier to do machine learning then to
use machine learning to create all sorts
of new symbolic constructs so within our
machine learning system we have all
kinds of recurrent networks and
sequences and so on which will work in
Nice automated ways we're also working
towards sort of higher-level
representations of neural networks and
machine learning right now what we have
looks like kind of things being passed
through wires in some kind of chain of
or graph of possible things there's also
the sort of the future involves things
like functional programming for for
neural networks and we you can already
see some things like net fold and things
like that which are the beginnings of
functional programming for neural
networks and various kinds of well net
net fold operator net nest operator
things like that so you know machine
learning is a is a as a field that is in
sort of hyper growth right now it was it
was quiescent for about 50 or 60 years
and you know when I worked on things
like neural Nets back in 1980
nothing much worked and it wasn't very
interesting but suddenly in the last
probably four years or so it's good
field that's gone kind of into hyper
growth I've seen such things maybe a
dozen times in my life in different
fields of science starting with particle
physics in the late 1970s and so on
where there's a field where kind of
every two weeks there's a new result and
that's kind of kind of an exciting thing
it doesn't last forever usually lost for
about five years and and maybe five to
ten years is typically the time frame
it's sort of interesting we're maybe
halfway through I think the hyper growth
period for machine learning and what's
what's notable about it is kind of
machine learning introduces a new class
of methods and then the question is what
can those be applied to and it's notable
that things like our image identifier
which is two and a half years old it's
still a state of the art image
identifier it's not that image ident
got better it's that we got to
understand more about how we can apply
these methods to a wider range of
different kinds of things so there are
all kinds of different use cases so for
instance here's a use case that's a
recent one that's in 11.2 so we take
some random image let's take a starry
night and let's try and now take what is
that
okay so let's do an imagery style using
the current image this is going to take
a current image let's make up so it
looks like okay there we go so what that
did was it made a it restyled the
current image this is sort of a
different kind of application of machine
learning and neural nets is restyling
images that way so let's do let's try it
again let's say that was a sort of fast
version we could try a really we could
try setting a performance goal so notice
there's a lot of automation in all of
this so there's lots of things
underneath the hood but here we're just
saying make it as good a restyling as
possible so it's tried again now that
doesn't look much like me um there we go
so now what now we'll actually see the
thing in real time running the restyling
it didn't do that last time because it
was too fast but you'll see the actual
iterations of the neuron that as it as
it tries to find an optimal restyling of
that picture given given the target
style that we had well so usually you
can actually hear the CPU running when
it's doing something like this because
it's really using all all threads and
everything um alright anyway so this is
it's gradually coming in more and more
started this is gonna take a long time
we're at 2% here but it's gonna be great
when it's finished um ya know you can
definitely see something starting to
come in alright we'd better stop this
here
alright let's um let's turn to to
something quite different the I want to
talk about that's yes let's let's talk
about let's talk about math
actually what was I looking at here I'm
maybe I'll show you one more thing about
neural nets and then we'll yeah let me
show you one more thing so so another
another big thing that we're doing is to
make a repository of neural nets and so
this is kind of the latest models they
get added every few days and they come
the things that you know once it's in
the literature in some paper
our goal is within a couple of weeks to
be able to have a version of it in the
neural net repository and hopefully
eventually people who write the papers
will put their things in the neuron that
repository set up so that you can
immediately use it so for instance let
me show you an example of of one one of
these so let me show you this is one
this is herbs if I can get it to come
back so it's just a very recent known
that doing another kind of function that
it's sort of surprising works this is a
network that is trained on geotag data
and its goal is to figure out given a
I'm so let's let's go ahead and and just
set this up so we'll say network equals
the Sun this thing that comes from the
neuro repository it's a big complicated
network there and now what we want to do
is to say let's get a picture of let's
get a picture of a prickly pear cactus
okay and the goal of this network is to
try and figure out where in the world
was that picture taken so it's something
kind of kind of weird that you might
have mad that that anything like that
could have possibly work but let's go
ahead and apply that network to that
cactus and it says okay it thinks it was
taken at that geolocation well let's
let's give it a little bit more room
let's say let's ask it that's simply not
what I want it there let's ask it to
show us to do that and figure out the 50
top places that picture might have been
taken so there's the result it's pretty
neat because some you know I don't
actually know where these characters
live but that least looks plausible if
you put in a picture of a pyramid it
will just go straight to you know Geezer
or whatever it was trained on 100
million images that were taken from
Flickr and other places
that are pictures of things around the
world and what's remarkable is how good
this is
and it's it's just an example of sort of
a what I I think we're going to see
increasingly as more use cases of
machine learning there are things that
are just kind of remarkable that they
could possibly work um okay let's um
let's change topics let me talk now
about that math so specifically let's
start off talking about calculus you
might think there couldn't possibly be
anything more to do in calculus but
actually we work on calculus we're
working on calculus for 30 years we're
gonna go on working on calculus forever
there's a lot of interesting things to
do here's the thing we recently added is
much more sophisticated limits so this
is a limb soup being computed come on
compute I don't think it's that oh there
we go okay that was a little bit hard so
that's a limb soup of some trigonometric
function we could perhaps ask it to
compute discrete limit of some solution
to some recurrence equation all these
kinds of things we could compute
multivariate limits all sorts of wild
and interesting mathematics that's
required to do these things okay
another another another area let's talk
about some computational geometry so
let's let's have some object here
there's a man just sponge so now we can
for example say let's take that and
let's find in 3d let's find if this
works let's see yeah there we go so
let's say let's take the region
intersection of the menja sponge with
that piece with that ball that filled-in
sphere so there's the results and now we
can take this object here and this
object is just a thing we can manipulate
as always so we can say what's the
volume of that object and will tell us
the result so or we could say if we want
to be a little bit more elaborate we
could say let's um let's get no refused
to do that for some reason okay that
surprises me okay so anyway we should be
able to tell it to integrate over that
particular region
oh it's a 3d region well that's why that
didn't look and you know what asking to
integrate is really pretty extreme I
think we should just ask it for the
numerical integral you know something is
wrong with my ability to quit things
here let's just see um see if this works
that's very odd very odd well anyway I
don't know why I'm having to do this um
that should work though let's let's try
it just to prove that this is not some
that we're not being I hope that well I
did this exact same thing that was
really stupid
um so much for that let's see so let's
so if I say n integrate here should be
able to do it I hope I don't know why
that that should be quite easy for it um
well okay in any case let's sum okay who
knows what's going on here
that um all right let me keep going
let's let's talk about other kinds of
let's try some other kinds of
geometrical well actually I wanted to
mention some other I want to just
mention a couple of other things well
here's an example of just a more
complicated region we can maybe do
something interesting with so let's say
we make an Anatomy plot so this is using
anatomical data we make an Anatomy plot
of a hand we could say just show us the
bones in the hand and now if we want to
we can actually it's fun we can we can
look at we've got a lot of new kind of
ok let's just get the the mesh
corresponding to those bones and then
let let me not some tempt fate but we
could do something we could try doing
all kinds of cool computations with this
but let's not do that actually one thing
we can do here this is fun
is to look at our Anatomy plot and to
say let's theme it like it
being Grey's Anatomy or something with a
vintage plot theme and so on anyway but
let's come back to math for a second one
of the things that's always an issue is
dealing with kind of the generality of
often language versus the kind of
elementary math that for example
students often like to do and so for
example for many years we had the whole
challenge of cube roots and we finally
got decided to introduce a function
called cube root which says that the
cube root of minus one is equal to minus
one rather than rather than the one
minus one to the one third we have the
same kind of issue with absolute value
so if I take an absolute value here and
I say what's the derivative of that the
it will just tell us well the derivative
is ABS prime because it doesn't really
know what to do because ABS could be in
general something that operates in the
complex plane we could now we've
introduced a new thing called real ABS
where it's assuming the argument is real
and then it can go ahead and just
compute the answer and we could go ahead
and unplug that and so on and I'll give
us the usual result okay so that's
that's a little bit on kind of math let
me turn to another area I'm gonna go
through I've got a lot to go through so
I'm gonna probably have gonna have to
speed up here this is audio so this is
now something which will capture audio
in real time so if I say hello hello
hello that will capture the audio of
that and now for example I could say
make me a spectrogram of that and I can
go and there's the spectrogram of me
saying hello a bunch of times and then
being silent there so and now we can do
all kinds of computation on this and so
there's there's lots of capabilities for
audio feeding into machine learning
we're working on voice to text and
things like that as well let's pick up
an image again let's see what some
things we can do with that so let's pick
up another current image go and now we
can take that current image
and we could say let's take that and we
can just do arithmetic on it let's
square it we get the result and let's
say let's take that image squared and
let's add the edge detect of let's say
the edge detect of that image to the
square of the image and we get a result
so we can treat images like like things
we can compute with let me show you
another thing you can do with images
which is kind of a actually using some
machine learning we'll be using more
machine learning let's do a web image
search for I don't know something like
this and now what we can do is take take
one of the images we get I don't know
some random image like this and we can
say that's a that's right now a bitmap
so if I go and expand it it'll be a
bitmap I could use the function image
graphics to try and guess okay I've got
a different one here let's let's try and
guess what the what a vector graphics
version of that image would be so and it
did a pretty pretty decent job here of
that so that's some that's another thing
so another area so one thing we're
always doing is to try and sort of tweak
and improve kind of make more convenient
polish the functionality of the language
so we're always looking for sort of
idioms that we can turn into functions
we have this whole internal effort
called ILD incremental language
development that's involved in doing
that so here's an example of something
which is kind of a actually I realized
this wasn't actually done by the
official ILD group but nevertheless
nobody nobody outside cares about that
but this is an example of a new function
stacked dateless plot so there's a
family of stacked plots that you can
make that will just give you cumulative
results and I could for example take the
same thing here and I could compute I
could say use plot layout that's a
general function that where the general
option that we're introducing so this is
now making a percentile plot of this is
in this particular cases the 10 most
populous countries as a function of
their populations the function of time
looks like no is it from 1600 on kind of
interesting actually so
okay well let's talk about some other
kind of language functions so for
example here's an example we have this
is this is a new one at eleven point two
take lists so what this does is it just
takes chops up a list not just like
partition and fixed blocks but this is
one that sort of successively takes
particular bytes out of a list there's
another new one find repeat we've had
fine transient repeat this finds the
actual repeat in a sequence of a
sequence perfectly repeats here's
another function capitalized with title
case so this is now using some machine
learning capabilities to try and figure
out what words should be capitalized in
a typical title that that you make
another elementary thing this is so
let's let's make a list here of numbers
okay we'll see that they go to
scientific notation but sometimes you
just don't want scientific notation so
we have a new rapper called decimal form
that forces the numbers to be in kind of
elementary non scientific notation
here's a here's a really kind of a a
straightforward function but it just
makes things easy reverse sort so what's
convenient about that is that you can go
ahead and just say reverse sort this we
didn't have that you would have to use
composition or something too we'd have
to apply a composed function to get this
to to work but there's just a convenient
thing that one needs all the time
another another kind of new thing this
is names of integers in lots of
different languages that's a number and
French as an ordinal actually one of the
things that we're we're getting pretty
good about is being able to support all
sorts of languages so let's ask for the
translation of the word computer and to
all the languages that we know so a
decent number of languages and that
number will increase and we could for
example take all those languages all
those results let's take the first word
for computer and let's transliterate it
whenever we can into a Roman script and
then let's for example make a word cloud
and we can kind of figure out what's the
most common
Flattr for computer in the various
languages of the world that's kind of
fun and I actually have to say that the
often language is really becoming an
extremely strong tool for linguistics
research and everything to do with
studying language and so on okay back to
talking about core language everybody
knows about the the rule operator in the
core Wolfen language something that's
new is the thing called two-way rule so
if I type 3 less than - greater than
that will turn into a two-way rule and
that's another inert kind of thing like
rule that's useful for a lot of
different purposes so for example in
graphs you can use two-way rule to
represent undirected graphs you can use
it in transpose to represent layers that
could be it should be interchanged
things like this okay
another area completely different kind
of thing this is the calculus of dates
so dates like numbers often come as a
certain granularity actually a little
bit like numbers a little bit like
precision and numbers you want a date
that is granular in the sense that you
want the week corresponding or the day
or the second or the instant and so
there's a whole kind of calculus of
granular dates that we've introduced so
that's the next date there we could for
example say take that plus 11 weeks and
now it has to know that's the month
including such-and-such a time and
there's a whole a whole structure to
that okay so let's see there's another
thing that we can do here let's do this
okay so this is this is also related to
dates so this is asking this is now the
wrapper dated which will ask us in this
case it's asking us the population of
the UK in 1920 okay talking and which is
kind of a another thing that we've been
very big on is sort of computational
humanities and computational history and
getting lots of different kinds of lots
of different kinds of of of historical
data into the system so for instance I
could say show me a geo list plot of the
Roman Empire actually would probably
give me a bunch of choices of which
which version of the Roman Empire I want
but there's a there's a result
I sure if I probably if I hit escape
there I can I can I'll see it asking me
different different versions of the
Roman Empire and/or the Byzantine Empire
let's try that one alright so there we
go there we've got our battles and now
we can go back to the when were these
battles anyway these are probably a
couple of centuries BC we can go back to
these battles from from outside of our
modern times and this is an example
actually we could go ahead if we wanted
to we could say let's do a bigger one
let's say battles in the Americans Civil
War and probably will get a much longer
list here of battles and we could say
journalist plot and there we go
she lost plot though is this kind of
interesting so there's 593 of these it's
kind of interesting to see the
geographic distribution of these things
and you can go in and and study sort of
the computational history ok that's
interesting I wonder what that one was
there or that one I learned I learned a
bunch of stuff there were I didn't
realize there was but most of it seems
to be concentrated where you would
expect it to be concentrated we can go
find out we can go ask it what those
what those ones are ok anyway so
somebody probably knows the history that
that says why those are there but ok so
another another kind of thing we can do
another new thing is some tied data
again that's something that you can sort
of compute historically for some reason
I wanted to know this particular tied
data and there we get the results and we
can now say we're computing those those
results and we can now say just show me
a plot and they're the tied that's going
from high tide to low tide and so on
alright another thing this is we've got
much more accurate geo elevation data
now so for example there's a picture of
Mount Everest at a high resolution we
could go ahead and okay if we want to be
more exotic we can say let's get the
Apollo 15 landing site which of course
is on the moon and we've also got geo
elevation data for the moon and I think
it was very lucky it didn't fall into
that that isn't a river that's that's
that
that's just a crevasse of some kind
which probably if we'd said plot range
to all it would have shown us the the
whole thing um and there we go that's so
yeah like it didn't fall into that um
the okay so another new thing that that
we have is geo geo image so this is
taking satellite imagery so now I'm
going to say give me a geo image for a
geo disk that's 800 feet around the
white house and that's so one thing to
mention about this this is using our new
integrated service mechanism so this the
actual data is coming from a satellite
data provider and it's charging small
numbers of service credits whenever you
use it but basically it's something
that's integrated into Wolfram language
is something that you can you can
immediately use it's the same way that
our web image search web search and so
on work so we can actually let's just
show an example there something like
that for web search so I can go ahead
and say do a web search for aardvarks
and I will now go and retrieve I'll do a
web search I'll retrieve the results
I'll get so for example I could take the
snippets from that web search it's
actually redoing the web search there
take the snippets and find out make a
word cloud of the various snippets from
looking up aardvarks on the web and I
could perhaps some I could take
following the aardvark theme for example
I could say let's just give me the first
sentence in the there's another
integrated service the first sentence in
the Wikipedia article about aardvarks
and why is it taking so long to get that
and then oh come on there we go
medium-sized burrowing animal and now I
can say translate that into Japanese and
this will be again using an integrated
service to do that so this is in
addition to all of our supported
connected services which are things
where you explicitly have to login or
you explicitly have to use a service
connection these are things that are
fully integrated into the language okay
other kinds of things we can do well
there's there's all sorts
places we can take data from so this is
so let me show you one new form of data
that we can get this is we can get a
current screen image so there's an image
of my screen and now for example I could
say take that screen image and colorize
a apply an image salience a filter to
that and kind of show me okay so yeah
the things people would care about on
the page of the places where there is
whether something typed in there okay so
it's so there's sort of a question of
all these things that we have in Multan
language how can we actually deploy
these and make use of these well so
there are as I mentioned there's there's
kind of a long story to that the desktop
has been our traditional way of
deploying our technology over the last
seven years we've also built deployment
in the cloud that's been a huge kind of
technical challenge because basically we
have to replicate all of the
capabilities of all the capabilities of
the of our notebook front end in the
Kyle but I can go ahead here and I can
just say I can just do everything in the
cloud that I would normally do and this
is now just running in a standard web
browser and we can get we can get all
these all the things that we would
expect in a notebook will actually work
now in a notebook in in the cloud and
it's been a it's been a big challenge to
basically build on top of JavaScript on
top of a pure web browser to build all
the elaborate capabilities that we
expect in notebooks
I think we've now finally got to the
point where we can really say this works
well and for example what will happen is
if you take a notebook even a very
complicated notebook and you you can
upload it from the desktop to the cloud
you can author it in the cloud when you
go to that web page where you go to that
URL of that notebook it will immediately
show up as fast as an HTML page you will
see a version of that notebook so you
can you can author content directly in
cloud notebooks and expect to treat that
like an HTML page
there'll be this little blue bar that
goes across the top that shows that it's
loading in the kind of interactive
content and once that blue bar has
finished it take a few seconds and then
you can start editing and computing
within that notebook so it's as if it's
like the web but it's been turned into
something that is completely editable
and interactive and computational so we
can also take this and I'm not sure
maybe I won't take too much time for
this but we can also take take the same
thing and come on we can also do this in
the cloud we on mobile so here I've got
some I've got the mobile app and I can
go ahead and do I don't know what a
sample notebook is here but but let's
sum let's pick this sample notebook and
now I can I can just do things directly
here I don't know what the sample
notebook is it may be something okay so
this is this is now just operating on my
mobile device here
come on the and I can go ahead and if I
want to I can edit can do all kinds of
computation here I could for example I
think the let's let's see how we get
this to wake up there we go there we go
so now I can I can start doing if I can
click in the right place I can start
editing this and computing and so on
it's much more exotic the other thing
you can do that's a bit more exotic is
to do actual programming on a phone
that's something let me not let me not
go ahead and actually do this here but
but it's it's kind of fun that you can
you can now actually write so I could go
as said and say create new notebook here
and I can actually be let's say create
an input cell I say you know 34 was a
factorial sign there's an exclamation
mark okay and I say evaluate and now I
can actually be doing computation and
writing code right here on a phone which
is which is actually has turned out in
my experience to be more useful than you
might
think that would be um the okay so the
okay so there's the the the next
important new thing is something that
we've been again working on for about
seven years which is to bring the in
addition to having the desktop and the
cloud also having native notebooks on
iOS and let's see if I can come on okay
so this is a big new exciting thing that
just came into existence in the last
couple of weeks this is the this is a
running natively on the iPad this is our
player application and now here's an
example of a demonstration and this
demonstration so everything is now local
here and I can go ahead and move that
slider and this will be computing
directly locally on the CPU of the iPad
and so you can take you can take any
notebook and what's important about this
you take any notebook you make it work
on the on the desktop it works in the
cloud directly on a web browser and it
works natively on the iPad um so that's
it allows you to deploy your content in
any one of those places okay well so
let's go back to talking about some how
and kind of this is a this is the story
this is kind of the long story of
notebooks which we invented back in 1988
they're finally after 27 years other
people seem to be getting excited about
things called notebooks that copy our
our notebooks but at the beginning we
were we had these kind of different
versions for the Mac and Windows and
next and annex windows and so on and
after a very long time we've now we long
ago merged those code bases and now in
more recent times we're ending up with
desktop and cloud and iOS all separately
implemented to be optimized for those
native environments ok so back to
talking about some deployment we can one
of the things that's also exciting is
being able to not just deal with
notebooks but
being able to deal with computations so
here I just said deploy a oops oops oops
you didn't see anything
okay back thank you okay so let me do it
again so this is this is just saying
deploy a form function to the cloud and
now I've got an app that I just created
and this app was finding the point on
the moon that corresponds to a
particular location on the earth so this
is the the lat/long on the moon that
corresponds to the position of paris on
the earth not the most exciting app but
just something that we can do in one
line and what the heck we could take the
same thing and instead of making a form
function we can make a form page and
that form page will then be something
where we can say oops I should have told
it to do that differently what did I do
wrong here form page oh yes okay so now
I could say for example New York City
here and it will go and do the
computation and then it will give me
another kind of well it will recycle
this page and ask me and so it's making
a little app that's just repeatedly
asking what do I want to look at in this
case I'm making an API so now I can take
this API and it's a Web API I could go
ahead and say give me the embed code to
embed that API as a piece of JavaScript
code and so on so with these api's that
are now running a little piece of
Wolfram language code you need a lot of
powerful things and a lot of companies
and people who've now built all sorts of
exciting things with with API functions
I'll show you an example of one thing we
built this last year this is our
precision eclipse computations website
so this is just a simple Web API what
was interesting about this project is we
didn't start it until really close about
two weeks before the Eclipse and this is
what we produced so if we say let's see
say something like let's try Jackson
Wyoming there we go it also completed
for that now it will go and call an ape
I and assumed we were connected the were
there we go
and it will call an API and that API now
computes all of these details we were
very proud of the fact that we actually
managed to get the the time of the
position of the arrival of the Eclipse
correct to one second at different
places on the earth that's sort of an
achievement I wrote a big blog post
about the history of how people have
tried to do this but anyway this is an
example underneath this is just one of
those api's that was deployed to our
cloud and then has a web interface in
front of it okay so another thing that
has happened in terms of API is is this
is more details for people who are
actually building api's and so on
there's a whole world of of additional
ways these are allowed this is a very
this looks like a very technical thing
as a forward option name but this is a
way of taking an API if you build an API
and you want to deploy it to other
people these are ways to automatically
have things like add timeouts and so on
to the API so it's a way of sort of
automating the process of building an
API same kind of thing here this is this
is a way of letting you just feed in
data not just on the on the URL line but
also in a CSV file or something like
that again something that helps sort of
automate how api's are getting built
well there's a whole whole lot of other
kinds of things around api's and so on
one of the big things that we worked a
lot on is a very infrastructural kind of
thing is the whole way that
authentication and permissions work in
the cloud it's a big giant zoo but
basically the it's sort of that the
general structure is who gets to do
walls and the who gets quite complicated
like people who are in this IP domain
this in this geo area etc etc etc people
who have this kind of authentication and
the what can also be complicated about
what kind of capabilities that they
should have so 20 case that's a that's a
thing that Tim has been just a
complicated thing that we built that's
very important for practical deployment
of Wolfram language and a lot of
different settings okay changing topics
we have so the coyote evaluate is a
function that will just go off from the
desktop for example and just go evaluate
something in the cloud so we just asked
what's the machine name of a machine in
the cloud here's another function clouds
submit clouds submit goes and makes an
asynchronous task that goes and does
something in the cloud this particular
case is not very exciting because it
just it will just go off and you know
nobody will hear the tree falling in
that forest it's it's just going to
compute machine name and not do anything
with it
but we can go ahead and say what is the
status of that task and that task will
long ago have been removed because it's
been it's it finished a long time ago we
can go ahead but but what gets more
interesting with tasks is there's
another form of submitting things this
is a URL submit where actually let me
explain that in addition to being able
to submit things to the cloud we can
also do a local submit which will cause
it to to start a local sub process that
will asynchronously do the computation
another thing we can do is session
submit which will actually create a
process within the same session that
will run when the session is idle and
that's important and then do the
computation there so these are it's sort
of a unified way of dealing with
asynchronous tasks that's very
convenient and you can schedule these
tasks or you can get them done
immediately and so on this is this is
what really gives teeth to the whole
asynchronous task business is the fact
that you can have a callback mechanism
you can have handler functions which say
upon various events do things so for
example here I'm doing a URL submit of
this URL with a certain query and I've
got a handler function that says when
the headers are receive print something
and I suspect if I could find the print
output here and see whether I have a
print window I don't well okay I would
that this will print to the print window
what the what what when these headers
are received and that will as this
happens there will be a callback that
gets these things to happen okay so
there's a
lot of low level stuff here you can look
at as people may know there's a whole
cookie handling system symbolic cookies
symbolic cookie handling there's a whole
mechanism for dealing with things like
that's an HTTP response represented
symbolically I actually happened to show
you the ping time thing before but let's
say we run ping 40 times going to
website there's a histogram of ping
times and so on we've got a lot of other
kind of low-level stuff that's been
added so this is sockets this is opening
a zero MQ socket that's something of
relevance to some people are going to
care about this it's a it's important to
us building things this is another
another new thing a sort of unified way
of binary seria of serializing
expressions in binary that's important
for storing the expressions externally
we also have libraries and languages
like Java and so on that let you
manipulate those serialized binary
expressions in external programs ok
another whole area is persistent value
this is a way of letting one persist
something letting one persist a value in
the system between sessions for example
or for example here what's important is
that there are different persistence
locations so you can say persist this
whenever the same front end is used
persist this whenever the same notebook
is used persist this when it's in the
same cloud is being used when you're
connected to the same cloud and so there
are different levels of persistence that
you can get that are that are useful for
kind of storing information that and you
can also use this persistence mechanism
to do initialization in a way that's
shared across different systems